how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything mcu and today we have some
wanda
vision news now one division is going to
be the first project that is going to be
coming from
marvel's phase four it's going to kick
off phase four in january
of 2021. and today we have some leaks
that give us a little bit of an insight
on certain characters costumes and
a scene that is apparently going to take
place at some time during the series
so we'll go over these leaks and talk
about what we could possibly see as far
as the scene is concerned in the one
division series but first if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a black
widow funko pop from the avengers game
so today we have some leaked merchandise
for the one division series from
monogram products 11 new bag clips each
featuring a version of a character from
the series
now it's important to note that every
one of these bad clips
is of wanda or vision except for one
person and that is monica rambo
and if we take a look at what her bag
clip looks like she's actually wearing a
black and white costume very similar to
her one from the comics so it looks like
they're trying to stick
fairly comic accurate with some of these
costumes and if you look pretty closely
we can see some type of a symbol on her
chest and it kind of looks like the
sword symbol
and this makes perfect sense because we
seemingly saw sword in the trailer for
the one division series and at this
point we pretty much know that monica
rambo will be working for sword
now as far as the rest of these bad
clips are concerned and the outfits that
wanda and vision are wearing we have
seen all of them
but one this one right here where it
seems like wanda is wearing a circus
style leotard and white gloves her hair
is up and is covered by
a top hat and vision is wearing a top
hat as well and what looks to be
a tuxedo now these costumes actually
fall in line with two rumors that we've
had recently and the rumors are kind of
one and the same the scenes just
differentiate a little bit but the
rumors are that wanda and vision are
going to put on
some sort of a magic show vision will be
the lead and wanda will be his
assistant the other rumor is that wanda
and vision are going to be
in somewhat of a circus and performing
acts as well which is basically the same
thing
either way it looks like wanda and
vision are going to be doing some sort
of magical act
in the series now if we take a look at
how these clips are presented the first
six of them are presented in black and
white and then the next five are
presented in color meaning that these
clips actually follow chronological
order of the series
so since it looks like the first four
clips are black and white in 1950s to
1960s ones we can probably expect this
magical
circus scene to take place in the 1960s
so it's going to be a scene that we see
fairly early on
in the show as it's expected that we're
going to get out of the black and white
part of the show fairly early on
now since wanda has the ability to warp
reality and turn it into essentially
whatever she wants it to be
it's hard to tell where the scene is
going to take place and what exactly is
it going to entail
the two of them could put on a full
blown out circus for a bunch of people
or this could simply be for their kids
but either way it's probably going to be
a pretty entertaining scene as
vision is going to be the one that is
going to take on the mantle of the
magician
and wanda is going to be his helper now
of course anything magical that vision
may do of course is going to be actually
done by wanda
and if i had to guess this is probably
going to be more of a smaller act
probably performed for their kids inside
of their house and maybe for some
friends as well or neighbors such as
agnes and it'll probably be a pretty
funny and heartwarming scene
so there's our tiny little leak today
for the wan division series a first look
kind of at monica rambo and what her
costume is going to look like
and a little bit of an inside look at
vision as a magician and
wanda as his assistant so let me know
what you think about this scene in the
comments down below would you like it to
be a small little act that they put on
would you like to see them perform in a
full
blown out circus let me know what you
think down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
me